and he's out of office well not yet
President Biden using the kid stairs in
stepping foot down in warm St Croy for
the long holiday weekend Joe is hoping
for a little rest and relaxation nearly
2,000 miles away from all the problems
he's facing in Washington which now
includes an impeachment inquiry his
son's Hunter's two indictments and the
Doom spiral at the border the big guy is
already on island time skipping a Year's
End news conf
it's not surprising why he's avoiding
the Press I mean who would want to
answer a question on why you have the
worst yearend rating of any modern
president seeking reelection Biden
probably also wants to get away from
Democrats bickering over whether he has
a shot at a second term some are more
candid about their
concerns I think Trump could win he
could win in Pennsylvania I think the
thing that Biden has to do is he's got
to enlarge the youth vote and and
minority vote he's got to say to people
here's why you vote and here's why it's
important you vote but I have to get
that sense of hope back and I think the
word hope is very important just like it
was with Barack Obama it sounds to me
like you think if the election were held
today Biden would lose well me and
everybody
else but Senator John fedman is firing
back at Carville for saying that Joe
could lose saying quote I'll use this as
another opportunity to tell James
carille to shut the bleep up my man
hasn't been relevant since grun
was a thing H Kennedy exception to that
remark run was a thing it will always
forever run forever yeah and I think
what James Carville is trying to do is
what David Axelrod is trying to do it's
what Jessica tarov tries to do they they
try to tell people the truth to get
voters to pay attention because although
the Biden nightes are wonderful
propagandists and they're telling all of
us how Rosy the economy is and how
stable the global picture is is actually
the president is in real trouble and
unless you Telegraph that to people
they're going to be very comfortable
with some of the economic numbers that
are coming out right now even though a
lot of them are feeling the pain so
they're trying to be truth tell I don't
know what John fedman is doing other
than trying to pick a fight with every
faction of the Democrat Party that boy
ain't right uh Jessica where are you on
the Federman Carville uh def you know
Saga the difference there I'm actually
team Carville and I'm team fedman I I
think that this is healthy I think that
Carville still has a place in the party
we are the big tent he responsible for
one of the more successful modern
presidencies ones that made Democrats
and Republicans happy when you say it's
the economy stupid you're saying that
because James carille was the one who
figured it out and said we should be
running on this in fact and I'm also
with John fedman in so farz and I
appreciate how you opened this and
saying that we're trying trying to be
truth tellers about this that at this
point Joe Biden is running there there
is no primary there's no getting him off
the ballot and so it doesn't actually
help Democrats to be having this
conversation about you know Dean
Phillips isn't really going to get it
done but as Gavin Newsome going to get
in is Gretchen Whitmer going to get in
this is who the candidate is and there
is like we talked about yesterday on the
show a lot of positive things about the
Biden agenda that you could be
discussing and fedman has been doing a
good job of that Carville is is in a
little bit of a Grinchy mood will come
around um but it's hard when you have
you know he's a party Elder what are you
gonna do right he goes on TV he James
carille no Biden is a party Elder Trump
is a party Elder and carille is a party
Elder the numbers the numbers are the
numbers and comparatively historically
Biden's approval according to gallet
from December sits at 39% Trump's was at
45% Obama's 43% % so he he's having some
problems here uh Joey and instead of
coming out and having an end year end
press conference to talk to the American
people about what he thinks are
achievements he bailed on that and when
the White House was asked about it they
said well he had a press conference with
the president of Ukraine and therefore
that is enough yeah it's funny like we
had this reporting a couple weeks ago
that Biden was upset at kind of what the
public perception was and he told his
team to circle the wagons and come up
with a strategy and then we realize the
strategy is to get him further away from
it everything I mean right now Anthony
blinkin might be the most powerful
person in DC doesn't that make you
worried I mean he's the one that's
that's leading the charge on what's
happening with the wars overseas he's
leading the or at least the diplomacy
he's leading the charge on the southern
border uh we're in a we're not in a good
place when it comes to perception of
leadership I'll give fedman and and
Carville all the credit in the world as
far as being uh party gues and having a
disagreement there and you know there's
a difference between what you've caused
and what you're responsible for that's
the lesson number one in leadership I
don't really care if Joe Biden's caused
all the problems I care that as
Americans we don't feel like he has the
wherewithal to fix them or the team to
fix them or the policies to fix them and
that's going to hurt him and it's going
to hurt him with young voters that care
much more about if they can get a job
and pay for an apartment and it's
hurting them with minorities and those
are two factions that Democrats think
they have a monopoly on so Tyrus what is
your perspective on vacation from
vacation while people are having a hard
time with things
like it's never a good look and
wherewithal Johnny it was the perfect
word because what we're seeing from our
president is lack thereof he barely
speaks to the Press so when he does
speak to the Press it's more heavier it
has more and his last two press
conferences have been brutal so now
we're seeing the Democrats are turning
the moderate Democrats are saying what
hey you had mayor Adams who was like he
won't even speak to me he's not helping
at all the sanctuary cities are a mess
and then carvo who lives in Louisiana
where I live is speaking on what he
seeing the same things that I'm seeing
in the City of New Orleans and he's
seeing what it's not just in the cities
it's spreading everywhere so people are
going that's why we're seeing the low
numbers and the're complaining and where
we're not getting from like previous
administration if there was stuff going
on Barack Obama would give us a speech a
press conference he break it down
whether you agree or disagree you have
the information do what you want we're
we're not getting those explanations
we're getting a if deferred to Trump did
it or well we already spoke and that's
the scary part I think his health must
be has to be deteriorating a little bit
because we're seeing less and less of
the impromptu speeches with no more
talking to the reporters from the
helicopter no more of this stuff and he
really should have had a press
conference going into going into the new
you think this this is just the usual
partisan bickering because I we were all
on TV during the Obama years and I heard
he's non-stop golfing I went back and
looked at the numbers he took 358
personal days of8 years unless you're
Jimmy car Carter who only took 78 days
across his four years you go on vacation
Biden is pacing the same as Trump except
Trump was going to his own places and
personally
profiting conf he was talking to the
single day I'll take a there was access
he would talk to M he bid gives you a
ramble and you're upset about that no no
I'm there's a difference between a
ramble like ramble is and I'm talking
fast and saying a lot of things than
going maybe Trump was giving a rumble a
rumble he was actually going back and
forth and engaging the press and
answering questions yes he was insulting
people but Jim aosta made a career by
standing up and being a blowhard and was
so incredibly disrespectful when you
contrast him with Peter Ducey who would
love to ask the president some questions
right now and and a two by two with uh
zalinski isn't the same thing as a press
conference when you have to answer about
immigration and crime and the economy
it's it's a lot easier to take golfing
vacations when interest rates are low
the economy is doing good and you
haven't started or or been involved in
three Wars as a matter of fact you
didn't start any as a president so the
things that we're talk and and the
Border was a heck of a lot better for
most of Trump's terms so yeah he took he
took vacation days uh Biden's outpacing
Trump actually Trump didn't didn't take
400 I mean the White House has this
problem where there's a disconnect
between what people are feeling their
everyday lives on the economy and what
the White House continues to say and
it's not the president saying it on a
regular basis it's the White House Press
Secretary it's their economic advisers
do you think that he would benefit from
giving some more access to reporters not
to just answer one or two questions at a
press conference about something
happening far away from the country but
about issues that are affecting
Americans every single day in a
year-long press conference that they are
not going to do whether it's end of year
start of year just because it's Tuesday
I think that President Biden does well
when he speaks to the public when he
talks about he goes to manufacturing
plants he goes to chips plants Etc talks
about the jobs that they're bringing
back there he is the ambassador of bomic
and I I have been very critical of his
Communications team that they are not
making it work whether that's a strategy
problem or a delivery problem and I
think that there are some great people
who show up and I love that they come on
Fox like Jared Bernstein is out here all
the time John Kirby is out here all the
time talking about what the
administration is doing yeah but it's
too far and few between he is the
president and he does have the ability
to say I want to talk to the Press
whenever I want he's not doing
that we got to go shocking new details
on the deranged lunatic who stabbed two
teenage girls while ranting about he how
he wanted to kill all white people hi
everyone I'm Brian killme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now